hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video i'm going to
talk about the recent book that i just
read
future foods how modern science is
transforming the way we eat
by david mcclements so as of my usual
book summary videos
i'll try and cover what i learned from
the book
in this video and summarize it in a
manner that
is much shorter than the time it took me
to read the book
and that's not a bad thing i'm just
quite a slave reader
but anyway the title of this book pretty
much summarizes what the book really is
about
how modern science is transforming the
way we eat
and that basically means that if we can
understand
the current foods how they're put
together how they're digested
how they're processed within our bodies
and understand
why we like certain foods what certain
foods are best for us to be eating
what's best for the planet
what's most sustainable we can use that
knowledge to help design
the future foods that we may be
consuming so who is david mcclements
well he's originally from the north of
england but has lived in california
ireland france and currently
he's now in massachusetts where he's a
distinguished professor at the
department of food science
at the university of massachusetts and
specializes
in the area of food design and
nanotechnology
and using this knowledge this book
covers a variety
of different topics that initially stem
from two original questions that david
had
firstly what should i and my family eat
and secondly how will we feed the
growing world population
and so as you'll come to learn both of
the answers to these questions are
extremely complex
but as david highlights near the start
of the book the richness and diversity
of the science underpinning the design
creation and consumption of foods
are unappreciated by most people
including the majority of scientists
and the point is that it's important to
actually try and understand the science
behind
these different technologies to
participate in the debates about the
proper implementation because they are
going to affect our future
and the future of subsequent generations
so i've used these two major questions
to try and break down this video
and so initially we'll talk about what
should i in my family eat
and the idea that it's not just
necessarily about
health but also about when and how to
eat
and basically the whole thing's very
complex and then
the second question how will we feed the
growing world population
comes down to the fact that the global
population could reach more than 9
billion people by 2050
and to be able to feed the world
priorities need to be made
in terms of meeting people's basic needs
ensuring what people eat are safe
but also maintaining a sustainable
environment and this is quite a
challenge that we have
on our hands at the moment but there are
technologies as we'll see in this video
that could help us achieve this goal in
a sustainable manner
although a huge amount of this food
could come from reducing the huge amount
of waste
that is currently produced from foods
estimates suggest that
a third of all foods produced globally
for human consumption
is lost or wasted equating to around
1.3 billion tons per year so to address
both of these questions
you need food scientists and these
scientists can have backgrounds
in a variety of different disciplines
from chemistry physics
biology engineering nutrition psychology
and social sciences and their aim is to
create safer healthier
tastier cheaper more innovative and more
sustainable foods
and so it may be surprising as to how
many different disciplines are involved
and i recently spoke about in a previous
video about
gastrophysics which basically
looks at how context in which foods is
consumed
has an enormous impact on its perceived
quality
so amongst many other things food
scientists are trying to build better
foods
and to be able to build better foods you
need to understand
firstly how foods are actually built
which involves
understanding the critical role that
proteins play
in determining the look feel and flavor
of conventional foods
and to identify potential plant-based
alternatives with similar properties
or other more sustainable options so a
key factor
in terms of what foods people like to
eat is the taste of a food
and so we have five basic tastes
sweetness
saltiness sourness bitterness and savory
however what you might not know is that
as much as
85 of the overall flavor of a food
actually comes down to the foods aroma
not just
its taste and so the aroma of a food is
the result of the mist of volatile
molecules that
arise from the surface of the food and
are detected by receptors in our nasal
cavity
and the really interesting thing is that
aroma is not just from the flavor
molecules that we breathe in through our
nose
called the orthonasal roots you also
get the section when food is already in
our mouth
and vapours travel up through the back
of our throats and to the top of the
nasal
cavity called retronasal olfaction
and foods smell differently depending on
whether the volatile molecules released
from them
enter either ortho or retro nasally
and the reason that happens is because
the aroma receptors
are organized differently in our nasal
cavities from back to front
and so it activates a different pattern
of receptors so i thought that was
pretty cool
but another thing that was really
interesting is that the aroma of a food
also depends on the food matrix and so
you could have two foods that contain
exactly the same flavors but smell and
taste very differently because of the
food matrix
so what does the food matrix really mean
well basically it means the precise
molecular environment
of a flavor affects how it is released
from a food and then perceived
an example used in the book by david is
the aroma of garlic in salad dressing
and so garlic is hydrophobic and so that
means it prefers to reside
in fatty regions so if you have a full
fat dressing
garlic mainly is dissolved in the oil
and so
few molecules of the garlic aroma are
released
whereas in low-fat salad dressing
the garlic aroma molecules are more
likely to rise into the air
and so the aroma is much stronger and so
the interesting thing to take from this
is the fact that the difference between
low-fat alternatives to high-fat
foods may have impacts on the aroma over
foods
and therefore its desirability to be
eaten and so the flavor release profile
how intense the flavor changes during
eating can be manipulated by altering
the feed matrix
however the food matrix can also alter
how fast the food is digested
is and why eating a diet rich in whole
foods such as nuts
beans grains and fruits and vegetables
makes us feel
full is because the fat proteins and
carbohydrates
are trapped in complex plant tissues
that are more resistant to digestive
enzymes and so are released more slowly
and slowing down the release of
nutrients such as glucose cholesterol
and fat into the bloodstream is now
being investigated by food scientists
to prevent ailments such as diabetes and
heart disease
and it can also be used to try and
design foods to increase the fraction
of beneficial nutrients to be released
such as vitamins minerals and
nutraceuticals
so that more of them can be absorbed by
the body rather than just passing
through
so the key takeaway is that simply by
changing the structure of the food it
can have a profound impact on our eating
behavior
body weight and health and that's
because it's not necessarily
just about the food structure but also
about how we eat it
as well david mentions the researcher
kieran ford at singapore institute for
clinical science
where his studies show that people who
eat faster
tended to eat more however this doesn't
necessarily correlate with the number of
calories
absorbed by the body because for example
studies have shown with nuts
that short chewers tend to eat more of
the nuts
but you get an increase in the
undigested nuts in feces
so there's less calories being extracted
so these topics seem to deviate
from the initial question of what should
we actually be eating then
and so what should we actually be eating
then
so david refers to what he considers the
best diet study
where they try to investigate the
association between carbohydrate intake
and mortality
and what they conclude is that the
suggested
energy intake from carbs should make up
around 50 to 55 percent
of your calorie intake however the risk
associated
with mortality seems to depend more on
whether the
protein comes from plant-based proteins
or whether it comes from animal based
ones
and so while the overall message seems
to be
what you've probably already had before
which is to eat things in moderation
and to favor plant-based foods where
possible but is this really the best
that we could do in the future
well maybe if we're going to generalize
but in the future
we might see more of the already hyped
personalized nutrition
and so personalized nutrition is just
that
what we should eat depends on ourselves
it depends not only on our genetics or
our microbiome but also on our lifestyle
and energy requirements and also our age
so
personalized nutrition aims to create
individualized dietary
recommendations that would hopefully
improve health and performance
and so whilst this maybe sounds trivial
it is far from that
and is very complex in terms of how it
could actually work
for example to ever do this accurately
whatever algorithms being used for this
personalized nutrition
would require your dna a whole range of
different biomarkers that
could be easily taken from your blood
and would also
probably be needed to be assessed on a
frequent time basis if not continuously
to have a good understanding of the
impact of the food you've consumed
on your health and performance and it
would also need to assess your lifestyle
your goals and a lot of this information
is information you may not want to be
providing to
different corporations or governments
rightly so but the author does rightly
remark that
we do already give up a lot of this
information every time we use the
internet i guess depending
on what browser you use such as what we
buy what we
read where we travel and our activity
levels
and another piece of information they
might also want
is your microbiome composition and so
there actually already is a company that
exists
that i've spoken about before in this
channel called fiom
and what filium claims to be able to do
is to take
information from your microbiome and to
give you
a personalized nutrition however like
all of these different
companies at the moment the different
algorithms or
machine learning techniques that they
use to make these nutrition profiles
initially needs to be trained on data
and so
over time over increased amounts of data
the assessments and outputs of these
different
algorithms will improve and so i guess
it just depends
well it just needs information lots and
lots
and lots and lots of information
and as i said as well at the idea about
potentially needing
continuous measurements doing blood
samples
or microbiome assessments isn't really
feasible
on a daily schedule so what you would
really need is personal biometric
sensors
and i guess the ultimate goal would be
to measure biomarkers without
having to collect and analyze biological
samples such as wearable devices
and it may not be too far into the
future until we see such devices
because some of them already exist for
example there are now
wearable devices that can measure blood
glucose levels continuously and
painlessly
which has been especially useful for
diabetic patients
and so the author's take is that there's
enormous potential for personalized
nutrition
if improvements in state-of-the-art
computational approaches
to collect the biometric data can be
achieved as well as the system's biology
to bring together the knowledge from
different sources
and to create a more detailed picture of
their relationship between diet and
health
in individuals and so if we go back now
to one of the
two questions that i introduced at the
beginning what should i
in my family eat i think it's pretty
clear that the answer to this question
is very complicated
and will be specific to individuals
so in the second half of the book david
addresses the second question
how will we feed the growing world
population and
the best way i thought to kind of go
through this section is to break it down
into three parts the first looking at
food biotechnology
then we'll look at food nanotechnology
and lastly we'll talk about
replacements of traditional animal
products with more sustainable and
ethical alternatives
so starting with foods by technology
david makes it very clear that he
understands that people have differing
opinions
over the use of food biotechnology such
as genetically modified crops
and he raises the point that we need to
just be able to listen to each other and
to understand the science
and the book just tries to address the
science that goes
behind all of these different
applications that said the risks and
benefits of these different technologies
should always be assessed so beginning
with genetically modified crops
the common examples are genetic
modification such that you can enhance
the growth of the crops and
improve its resistance to different
diseases and so the idea being that
the crop yield is greater and so this
could help create more food for the
growing population
but genetic modification can also be
used for bio-fortification
for example genes of stable crops can be
altered so
plants naturally retain more iron and
iron deficiency is currently the most
common form of micronutrient deficiency
in the world
so these applications have health
considerations as well as
sustainability applications and it can
also be used to eliminate harmful
substances
for example it has been used to create a
new type of wheat with much lower levels
of gluten
gluten can cause an autoimmune response
in some people
resulting in the condition celiac
disease so by improving yields
resilience and versatility
food biotechnology has continuous
potential for the future
however david does reiterate that it is
impossible to say
that all genetically engineered foods
are completely safe
but it is also wrong to say that just
because a food has been genetically
modified
that it is unsafe and highly respected
scientific organizations
actually strongly support the use of
genetic engineering in foods and
agriculture
based on the fast body of literature
including the world health organization
so i knew quite a bit about food
biotechnology before reading this book
but what i didn't know so much about was
food nanotechnology
which is what david specializes in so
this phrase may sound a bit scary but
nanotechnology refers to creating and
utilizing structures with minuscule
dimensions
so it's just working with things that
are very small and the
benefits of doing this is that very
small structures
have unique properties such as one
their small size obviously but second by
having such a small size they have a
much
larger surface area to volume ratio and
that can be exploited
and lastly they have high reactivity due
to the fact that the properties of
matter
inside particles change when they become
very small due to quantum effects
but don't worry we won't go into that
because i don't really understand it so
how will food
nanotechnology help with solving the
solution
for increased food demand well david
gives a couple of examples in the book
such as feeding plants with nano
fertilizers
and protecting crops with nanopesticides
but the coolest example
in my opinion are sensors made from
carbon nanotubes that can be absorbed by
plants
and can actually send signals to a
smartphone when a crop becomes
contaminated with pesticides
and so this comes from research in a
nature paper that came out
in 2016 which you can see here and it
goes into more detail about how the
system would actually work
but the idea is that only a couple of
the plants would need to
have their sensor and they could be
indicators for the whole crop
and so it wouldn't necessarily be that
you're consuming
these carbon nanotubes along with your
salads i don't know
anyway david highlights that there are
three main hurdles
before we could see nanotechnology
becoming widespread
in foods firstly food nanotechnology
would need to become
economically viable and become more cost
effective than competing technologies
secondly there'd have to be no health or
environmental risks with using these
different nano technologies
such as these nano fertilizers and then
lastly
and probably the most important it would
have to be accepted by the public
and so lastly we'll look at how
traditional animal products can be
replaced with more sustainable and
ethical alternatives
and so the reason that doing this
achieves the second question
of how will we feed the growing world
population
comes from the quite alarming statistics
that
whilst meat consumption only makes up
around 15
of the energy requirements of the global
population
it uses around 80 percent of the
available
agricultural land for either grazing or
producing fodder
however it should be stated that the
environmental impact does differ
depending on the kind of meat
with beef being more damaging to the
environments than
pork poultry or fish production however
it should be stated first that
the meat industry has become efficient
in using
every part of the animal including the
skin bones
and hooves to create other products such
as converting it to gelatin
which is used in the creation of yogurts
for example
also david also mentions that in the
future there will definitely still be a
place for animals
partly because animals can live on land
that isn't suitable for arable
production
and they can also convert grass leaves
husks shells
into high quality sources of protein
vitamins and minerals
so what alternatives are there well it's
very likely that you've either seen in
shops
and potentially even tried yourself
plant-based alternatives david addresses
plant-based alternatives by looking at
plant-based burgers
for example you have plant-based burgers
produced by impossible foods and also
beyond meat
but to get anywhere close to actually
mimicking the
meat's burgers you need to understand
the physics and chemistry of meat
structure
including that of the muscle fibers the
connective tissue
and the adipose tissue in whole meads
and also how
those different structures and
components change during the cooking
process
and one example is the fact that meat
goes from this reddish color
when it's uncooked to brown when it is
cooked
and that's due to the oxygen being
strongly bound to a protein known as
myoglobin
and when that temperature change occurs
during cooking
there's a structural transformation of
this protein myoglobin
such that oxygen is released and there's
an iron k factor in this molecule as
well
that loses an electron and actually
transitions the collar from red to brown
so how could that be mimicked using
plant-based alternatives
well impossible foods identified a
plant-based alternative to myoglobin
leg hemoglobin and it comes from the
root nodules of soybeans
and so this can give the plant burger a
red meat like appearance
and also the meaty flavor so there's
definitely a lot of research going into
plant-based alternatives at the moment
but this isn't the only solution another
way that you can actually consume meat
in a more ethical manner comes from
cultured meat
and so that's where beef pork chicken or
fish can be grown in a lab or a factory
from living cells
taken from animals without having to
kill them the way this is done can be
described through
three steps first of all you have the
collection stage
and so this is where cells are taken
from the living animal
and so these cells can be stored and
used later on
and it's been estimated that only 150
cows
could in theory produce all the beef the
world currently needs
once you have these cells the second
stage is the proliferation stage which
kind of given by its name is when
the cells grow and they replicate and
then lastly you have the maturation
stage
so here the conditions of the
environment
in which the cells are growing is
altered so you get the desired
cell type for example if you're wanting
to make beef you'd want them to be
generating
muscle adipose and connective tissue
cells
so as a scientist who has much
experience with growing cells in a lab i
honestly think
this is really ingenious and really
awesome and so if you're also interested
you should check out
a video on one company that is
developing cultured meat
i believe it's just pronounced just and
you can watch a video of them
generate chicken nuggets from a chicken
that they called
ian and they eat these chicken nuggets
whilst ian is like just walking about
besides them so that's kind of cute
but the interesting application of this
is that
you can grow meat from just like one or
two cells from a live
animal so what if we took one of our own
cells
yeah it's a little bit grim kind of
freaks me out when i read it too
i mean i definitely would only ever
consider eating meat from my own cells
i don't know but the point is that
it's possible and continuing with
neophobia
fear of new foods and disgust and other
possible
future foods or what is already
considered a food just not so much in
western culture
is the consumption of insects or
entomophagy
to be precise so the ethical benefits of
eating insects is the fact that
most edible insects don't have a central
nervous system
so don't feel pain and in terms of the
sustainability
insects are more efficient at converting
feed into food
and leads to fewer greenhouse gases than
animals and they can eat waste such as
wasted food crops
to grow and there's also the potential
to eat insects that would otherwise be
pests
for other plants but if eating bugs
still creeps you out
then there's also the potential for the
insect to be dried and ground into
flowers
however what might concern you is that
we're already entomophagists
the fda apparently allows a certain
number of insect parts and certain food
products
for example 20 maggots per 100 grams of
mushrooms
35 fruit fly eggs per 230 grams of
golden raisins
and 475 insect fragments per 50 grams of
ground pepper
yum anyway along with these other
technologies eating insects
the safety considerations will also need
to be taken into account
for example they may have toxins it may
change our microbiome
however so far the european food safety
authority
have reviewed evidence and said that
there's no more risk consuming insects
over other forms of food as long as
they're handled and processed correctly
to ensure their safety
so maybe we'll be seeing insects a lot
more in the future
and so the last alternative that david
mentions
are microbial meat and you most likely
have heard about this
for example from quorn the mycoprotein
produced by the fungus fusarium
phenonatum
and along with insects and plant-based
alternatives
the advantages to using microbial
species
is that they reduce food waste they
obviously use
much less land and produce much less
pollution
and an exciting advance mentioned by
david
is from a finnish company referred to as
solar foods
and they claim to make food out of thin
air
effectively they're coaxing autotrophic
bacteria into producing
a nutrient-rich edible protein using
only air and sunlight and a few minerals
according to their presentation their
novel protein
solene requires 10 times less land than
conventional agriculture
a hundred times less greenhouse gases
are produced
than meads and it doesn't cause
pollution because it uses a closed
system
the challenges they face will be scaling
up and using their product and
integrating it into
different food products that people will
actually want to eat
but a really cool use of this technology
would be
if we ever go to mars or the fast
astronauts to go to mars
in terms of being able to generate good
food source
bacteria that can generate a protein
from minimal
inputs would be really desirable so to
put all of this information together
david concludes that he's partially
convinced
that science and technology must play a
critical role in ensuring a healthier
and more sustainable food supply
and the best tk message creating word
for words
the future of our food supply is too
important for us to make decisions based
on irrational beliefs
rather than sound evidence and the point
is we need to become more informed
to listen engage with others who have
differing opinions
and advocate for the future we believe
in through our actions
purchases and foods so hopefully this
video has given you a good very brief
probably
not that in-depth overview to this book
but i hope it gives you some
insight into what we could see in the
future and
how important science is to these
different applications
and generally i think yeah the book was
really interesting and
got me excited and fascinated at the
same time it's always a good thing
so go check out the book there's a lot
of things i didn't
get to mention so yeah
so i hope you've learned something and
as always thanks for listening